el de francia es un balance agridulce si
bien se han reducido los contagios de
kobe 19 el primer ministro aseguró que
sería irresponsable levantar el
confinamiento mientras el país registra
la peor tasa de hospitalizaciones desde
el inicio de la pandemia no está en
nuestro objetivo es poder permitir una
nueva flexibilización de medidas durante
las vacaciones navideñas para que los
franceses puedan pasar las vacaciones
con sus familias
pero esto todavía está en vilo por ahora
las autoridades mantendrán el bloqueo
por dos semanas más y evaluarán la
situación
italia no está mejor que francia los
hospitales están al borde del colapso y
los profesionales de la salud saturados
desde la primera ola denuncian que las
cifras de ocupación hospitalaria que
maneja el gobierno son irreales
las acciones de los hospedajes la
situación actual en el hospital es que
casi no tenemos camas disponibles
estamos trabajando intensamente con
sacrificio asumiendo una gran carga de
responsabilidad especialmente los
trabajadores y enfermeras ciudad
bastante operadores o estos de jim
fermín en el medio del aumento de casos
las autoridades italianas empezaron a
analizar las aguas residuales para ver
si pueden predecir el avance del virus
en españa las restricciones por la
segunda ola de kobe 19 ha provocado
manifestaciones en ciudades como sevilla
la situación es absolutamente lamentable
es inexplicable todo lo que está pasando
cuando en otros sectores hay más
contagios que en el sector de los bares
y encima nos han demonizado nos ayuda a
nadie y nos están dejando morir pero por
la cara vamos
pero no es solo el sector del turismo y
la hostelería los médicos le han pedido
ayuda directa a los políticos para
rescatar financieramente al sector de
salud uno de los más exigidos durante la
pandemia